we are team ninja turtle and we're going
to show you turtlebot today
i'm a part of team ninja turtle in a
group with four other girls and we were
able to successfully run our floor
routine for the 212 olympics
today actually went really well our
robot actually did perform the way we
had hoped it would did all the routines
that we were supposed to do
it was supposed to do flip around the
high bar do a few tricks and then
eventually try to stand up straight
let's try
this robot was all laser cut it had code
it knew what to do and we just pushed
the play button and let it go
212 of the class is called intro to
robotics
robotics is very much a dynamics problem
and a controls problem
it's a pretty cute robot you know it's
like very adorable and small throughout
the process the robot felt unreliable we
would run the code one time and it would
work perfectly
even two or three times in a row and
then maybe we'd take a lunch break or
maybe not even and then suddenly we'd
run it and it just wasn't working and to
figure out why did it work this time and
not this time it was just like constant
struggle
we started off with a crazy ambitious
idea and in the end when we eventually
scaled it down we had to put in a lot of
time in it a lot of hours in a short
amount of days to complete it
i think in any project like this you're
always crunched for time tas were there
till like 1 2 a.m and they had pizza and
drinks
if the group wanted to stay until six in
the morning i think that the option was
there to do that
at some point we just had to say hey
we've got what we've got we're gonna go
in there and just do our best
i think what was most satisfying was the
teamwork and being able to work in a
group and really know that everyone was
really invested in this project the
hands-on aspect is actually where we did
really all the learning
it's more than just like going to
lectures and sitting sitting in a
classroom just taking notes and taking
tests and doing homework it's actually
getting to really apply what you've
learned
and try to also use your creativity side
and actually making something new
now we're able to know
how robots
actually work not just how they
theoretically work
it just fueled my interest in robotics
there's so much work to do there's so
much advancement left in the field
there's so much like more progress that
can be made